hi guys it's ideas of Ice and Fire and
today we're going to be talking about
macro engineering and Larry Nivens
Ringworld series macro engineering is
the application of extraordinary
large-scale design projects now of
course in the real world with macro
engineering we are limited by our amount
of time and our amount of resources but
in science fiction anything that can be
imagined is possible
[Music]
Larry Nivens 1970s Ringworld novel
involved a space expedition to a distant
destination the race of aliens known as
the puppeteers had detected it and
become interested the cautious race
assembled a team of two humans and a COS
NT to investigate what was there was
unlike anything any known race had ever
seen a marvel of macro engineering the
ring world the ring world consisted of
even greater mass than the planet
Jupiter it was six hundred miles long
with the radius of 90 million miles and
a total of 1 million miles across
edge-to-edge it was made of solid matter
as opposed to gas dust or asteroids this
was no naturally forming structure the
ring which wrapped around a star had an
atmosphere equivalent in thickness to
that of Earth and slightly less gravity
the ring rotated around the star in
order to provide artificial gravity in
the system containing the ring world
there were no other planets no other
celestial bodies at all in fact
including asteroids and comets the scrit
which formed the floor of the ring world
is a translucent material the material
produced almost no friction absorbed
almost all radiation and subatomic
particles it encountered and rapidly
dissipated Heat the ring world's Grif
was also very strong and could not be
damaged by most weapons the ancient
civilization which had built the ring
world had possessed a break technology
everything there including the world
itself had to have been brought from
some other place and unlike an
earth-like planet which possessed
natural resources such as metals the
ring world's base consisted of a strong
foundation material
which could not be worked it is
speculated early on that the creators of
the Ring world necessarily must have
possessed an easy method of elemental
transmutation in order to maintain
civilization the ring world had been
this ancient civilization solution to
the problem of overcrowding it was
equivalent in size to about 3 million
Earth's the ring world was a kind of
compromise between a Dyson Sphere and a
planet
the Explorers found the ring world to be
amazingly flat the Seas of the Ring
world were shallow the vegetation earth
Lake the ring world was also protected
by an automatic meteoroid defense system
to provide a day and night cycle
resembling an earth-like planet the ring
world was equipped with a secondary ring
of atmospheric shadow sweaters which
rotated providing the ring world with 30
hour days the construction of the ring
world remains a mystery throughout the
first two ring world novel it is assumed
that in order to build such a structure
a tremendous amount of energy and
resources would have been required and
the amount of time necessary to complete
the project would have no doubt in
several human lifespans by the time the
puppeteer is sent an expedition to the
ring world the civilization which had
built it had fallen the inhabitants had
devolved into many primitive societies
many of which had built mythologies
around the ones who had engineered the
ring world the ring world probably
couldn't exist in real life at least not
in the way it's described in Nivens
books it was pointed out by many years
ago that due to the fact that the
central mass of the ring world did not
move while the ring itself rotated that
the ring world could not maintain its
stability without additional thrusters
which could provide some kind of active
stabilization the ring world would have
been unstable the ring world series is
definitely a classic of the science
fiction genre and it's definitely worth
reading due to the sense of exploration
and wander
at the books in VOC hi guys I've been
working on a graphic novel about witches
in the fictional kingdom of morass if
you want more information about this
graphic novel click the link in the
description to get put on my mailing
list